[Music]
anyway the upstairs back did you guys
hear Michaela got his channel back
though
it just happened
I did this and I'm sorry
no you know
no no no no no no shut up
we done
good yes thank you
anyway
the oopster
I had one of the greatest runs in radio
ever I don't have to go to a job doesn't
this suck
those are the highlights Fall From Grace
I know doesn't this [ __ ] let me get rid
of him he can't handle this
let me get rid of him he can't handle
this Opie you do have money and you're
right you don't have to but the problem
is it's not it's not people saying
you're washed up in terms of your washed
up and you're poor relevant you're not
relevant anymore you don't matter you're
probably your problem Opie is that you
made all your money on the big Charlie
Brown and now you have the same amount
of money that just keeps getting smaller
until you die or unless he makes a deal
with you let's not make a deal could it
do
[Music]
uh-huh
oh [ __ ] purple and black what's what
what am I supposed to be doing
um radio
I mean probably I would love to know
what people think I should be doing with
my life
what I want you to do or like immense
okay yeah apologizing to people making
an actual like real honest moral
inventory of what you've done in your
life you know
I had one of the greatest runs in radio
ever well Anthony and Jimmy did
and now I get to uh enjoy my family more
you'd say that but you were at the beach
and I never saw them never see you with
your family ever
my friends more
who
who are your friends yeah all your
friends are dead by your hand we're dead
to you yeah well there you go I live 500
feet above the streets of New York City
that's not a positive that's not a brag
and then on the weekends and more than
afford parking I have to wait on the
curb every day and do talk shows there
because I won't pay for the following
mirrors yeah
so sad I know you said it's joking but
it's real and it's sad people steal my
mirrors sometimes
[Music]
it's weekends because I don't have to go
to a job
I get to go the Kennedy's not around
anymore
McKinley Dead Carl dead everybody dead
Steve Khaleesi she's dead
ocean and take long walks and do Beats
you're the Grim Reaper of radio Hopi
that's what he is he's the Grim Reaper
he's the Grim Reaper the Smasher of
cakes
the restorer of radio shows the Ripper
of employees pooping
complainer to HR
and go fishing and go to my friend's
pool
they go on a couple of my friends boats
and sailboats oh my God my life first
off let me explain something to you uh
from someone from Florida
sailboats suck okay Yachts Yachts are
the superior boats okay any boat that
doesn't have a motor in it you can go
get [ __ ] Yachts are the superior boat
okay you want something with a deck that
has a toilet
and just a you know bedroom for you you
know you know a couple people to hang
out that's it that's all you need yeah
if I'm not if I'm gonna float slowly
through water I'll go to a lazy river if
I'm gonna get on a boat I wanted to go
[ __ ] like 90 miles an hour but my
relatives floated slowly on the water
has come to America but I feel you buddy
I'm with you yeah if Royce wants to
float slowly in the water he'll tie a
bunch of tires together or turn a
[ __ ] 53 Buick into a boat yeah
whatever
Flex Seal baby
I guess I was supposed to what Chase um
chase the radio dream my entire life
you did you tried you you you literally
were so cocky that you you burned
everything down because you thought I
could do this on my own and what do you
mean didn't you just say like the last
time we saw your video you had a big
thing in the works remember that what
was what was that what's the deal what's
going on buddy yeah where's the big
where's the big that's the big
announcement
um but like I'm good man I'm good you're
well good
I had one of the greatest runs in radio
you said it four times who are you
convincing
and now I get to just high in the sky
above New York okay
living in the clouds I drive a Dodge
Stratus that's what he's doing
wake up in the morning throw on a live
stream
um fool around a little bit uh and then
cut some of this up into a podcast that
makes a okay money no it doesn't I've
done senior metrics stop it
stop it it does not make okay money
you're [ __ ] lying yeah we make more
money than you do on the internet now
and we don't make enough and we don't
make enough money so so shut up yeah